in the history of revolution by our
friend Trotsky he makes this claim that
Russia friend my friend Trotsky's also
illegal it's it's because of the name no
but he may he makes this claim that
racial revolution will be the last
revolution but and it's it is because he
at that time he fought that that
revolution would transform the mass of
individuals the Masters into individuals
a united humanity which will cherish
freedom and human dignity so the final
question is what kind of revolution are
we waiting for should we working on to
to have this idea that we will have this
free society where people can live in
dignity and a united humanity so let's
make around deciding
a
revolution which
what is bases itself on what appear to
be the the the desires of the majority
of the population and which are not that
difficult to find out and and
and makes a kind of means that some of
the desires and the
hopes are unattainable but but
nevertheless due to base itself on what
the nest of the people want and not what
the Internet in the past all revolutions
in Russia have been what the
intellectuals thought
the mass of the people wanted and so I
think such a revolution might one day
Michael well first of all the last
revolution that Trotsky referred to the
Russian I think remembered the 100th
anniversary and days ago and we spend in
Czechoslovakia our whole childhood
learning about the grade of revolution
and
gradually we discovered and we realized
that first of all it was a revolution
but a military coup second it didn't
take place in October but in November
and said it was not a date so
that that's our experience but
there is some kind of a revolution that
I
could envisage and that part of Havel
and visit in his
speech to the joint session of the US
Congress he famously said that the
salvation of this world lies in the
human heart in the human power to
reflect in human humbleness humility and
first and foremost in human
responsibility and I I believe that a
large part of the current crisis is that
the responsibility that each of our each
of us feels for not just for ourselves
and our families but also for people
around us and they destiny has become
has has disappeared
I'm in favor of conservative revolution
I think that sow has roots and roots of
sow leads to heaven so I return to the
roots it's not necessary returned to the
earth it could be returned to the
heavenly mother land and this Richard
because revolution etymologically in
Latin signifies return and I think it's
always was possible because I don't
believe in a linear time I think the
time is different so I think that a
communist revolution was
bad one that was a very very very
negative experience and that was a kind
of simulacrum of real revolution that
was prepared in the beginning of the
century and the last word I would say
that revolution should be humanistic
because we are endangered to a
our human nature and maybe in order to
save it or to reaffirm it we really need
not only evolution because evolution
lives in some other direction but real
and serious and very problematic and
dramatic at the same time revolution
I say a man Frantz Fanon an algerian
talks about how in a struggle is that we
discover our humanity so I would say a
struggle for democracy a struggle for
understanding liberalism for advancement
of it on the top of that when it comes
to questions of revolutions one of the
reasons why I have been against
intervention from the West is that I
wish for the Arab Muslim world to own
their own revolutions to be allowed to
achieve a certain degree of maturity
that even if there is loss of life which
will be colossal at all points under
dictatorships or without it I would have
loved to see the Iraqis would have
liberated themselves from the hands of
Saddam as I would have wish as well the
same to happen in Syria but not to shock
people but at this point in my life
after watching so much of the violence
that is prevailing the moment of crisis
and the u.s. in Western world in Asia
and everywhere else I like the last
revolution to be a non-violent
revolution I would say I like to go back
to Gandhi and trying to find seeds of
that thinking that we must have the time
the ability and the tolerance to not
resign to violence not resigned to
military actions and instead at a time
when everybody else is I'm sure calling
for more power and more aggression I
would say it is upon intellectuals I am
a big believer in non-violence and I
believe that will be the salvation of
humanity at the end of the day if we
want to survive we live in one planet
hurt it's a common home of all of us and
in order to save it whether it's from
environmental disaster or from military
disasters history has proven looking at
the old conflicts in the and all the
other parts of the world with all
cyclical nature of everything the eaves
and flow we have to start any way of
thinking and reject violence as any
means to achieve a civil human society
so for me that would be the day I may
not live to see it but like
the the notion someone thought of
stopping slavery because it was wrong
not because we thought it would succeed
but because it was wrong and I like to
propose that in our educational system
we must start to talk about non-violence
as an ideology and try to understand and
find means of actually implementing it
so as a thought because it's the right
thing to do to stop violence at all
forms and not because we may succeed but
because it's the right thing to do
[Music]
I
think there will be no end of the day
and I think there will be no last
revolution I think there will be no
definitive climactic event I believe in
moral progress and I believe in social
progress but I believe that this
progress is neither linear nor
irreversible nor
incontrovertible I think the struggle
for this progress is unceasing
absolutely unceasing and a step forward
will provoke two steps back and our
children will still be fighting for some
of the principles that we're fighting
for now and I'm reminded there was an
important sixth early 16th century
Jewish thinker in Prague who once said
he said in a sermon on the subject of
frivolity of all things he said in a
sermon that the human being he said may
be defined as the creature that aspires
the perfection this is an old
Aristotelian idea nothing original and
then he said but if the definition of
this creature is the aspiration to
perfection than in such a creature
perfection itself must be regarded as a
shortcoming and a flaw
don't I have to say I think that defines
very well actually our own national
aspiration which constantly falls short
of the mark but is then constantly
working to achieve the mark knowing that
it's working to achieve it that is what
we're all about trying to create a more
perfect union and our union is
profoundly imperfect and we're
discovering frailties and
vulnerabilities with it every day a part
of it requires coming back as Leon said
to some first principles and reaffirming
them but you know our what our great
realist philosopher Reinhold Niebuhr
said very famously that
man and woman's capacity for justice
makes democracy possible but their
inclination toward injustice makes
democracy necessary and that's exactly I
think something that needs to be
reasserted look you had a very
interesting discussion also in the first
panel and you mention Thucydides in the
context of our Chinese friends
antitheses was also very famous for
something called the facilities trap
that is the notion that as one country
Rises it inevitably finds itself in
conflict with the countries that it's
overtaking the one country at least
historically thus far that's managed to
avoid the trap was actually the United
States after World War two when we
emerged as the sole superpower we could
have done a number of things we could
have done what we did after World War 1
which is retreat come home and then of
course we had economic dislocation we
became
protectionist we had dictators rise in
Europe we became isolationist and we
wound up with a genocide we wound up
with a global configuration we wound up
with an economic crisis that spanned the
world after World War two we made
another decision instead of imposing the
power that we had over everyone else we
helped design a system in which at least
on paper everyone had a voice and
everyone had a vote and it was
counterintuitive because we restrained
our own power we bound ourselves to the
same rules and obligations and others
and this was at the essence in the heart
of enlightened self-interest the result
of this system was for all of its
imperfections other countries did not
bandwagon against us in the way
throughout history they had won one
power emerged we had new markets for our
products that was the self-interest we
had new partners to deal with complex
global challenges and new allies to
deter and ultimately counter aggression
and that system
for all of its imperfections in the fact
that apartheid lasted colonialism lasted
not all conflict ended nonetheless wars
between the great powers stopped we
haven't had any there was a certain
amount of stability and predictability
and transparency that allowed other
countries to grow and a global middle
class to start to emerge hundreds of
millions of people lifted out of poverty
and again if you look at the very big
picture at the highest level the world
even yes not just the United States the
world over the last 70 plus years is
healthier wealthier wiser more secure
and more tolerant despite everything
we're seeing in this particular moment
because this arc is not a perfect one
it's not linear as leon said but it is
in danger and unless it's defended but
also amended to account for the fact
that too many people do not feel part of
this story then it will fail but then
what will happen instead of a liberal
world order with its manifest
imperfections we will have an illiberal
world order and the values that the
liberal order order seeks to advance
democracy human rights the freedoms we
were talking about earlier the
progressive norms that it tries to bring
with it protecting workers protecting
the environment protection intellectual
property all of that will go by the
wayside and we'll have this multipolar
world but it will be and they'll be in
order and Russia will control its area
its sphere of influence China will do
the same thing in its but it will be a
liberal and I don't think that's the
world we want to live in okay the final
words thank you Tony
to you charge actually attrition the
last revolution or because you're the
leader of the inner party which means
Renaissance party what is the kind of
Renaissance or last revolution you're
dreaming about I think that our world is
developing in bad way in false way
we see
starvation is in part of the world we
see part I'd
cleansing sort of eradication of some
people like what happened in in some
countries
we see
ahjummoni the superpower dominate other
people's and
we see many military interventions
we have to we the the world needs
permanent revolutions not wonderful but
to revolt
starting by a revolt against ourselves
our desires our regu ISM
because this is needs
real educate people to
struggle against their bad desires we
need to revolt against poverty in the
world
there is disability between rich and
poor
so we need the revolution against
poverty against intervention military
we against any sort of humanity we have
to save
natural natural
state is in danger
by the bad way of
development so
we have to revolt permanent evolution as
the
Quran said yeah you hanasu in Naha
Omnicom in the current version now comes
Ruben rockabilly tarfful or
my people we have created you from
male and female not to fight each other
but to know each other thank you
okay